bei uns zu gast der österreichische
bundeskanzler sebastian kohls in diesen
tagen in berlin unterwegs herr kurz das
zimmer impfstoff beschäftigt europa
beschäftigt auch sie astra zenica soll
jetzt wieder verimpft werden sie haben
gar nicht aufgehört damit warum haben
wir das ein anderes in deutschland
anders gemacht warum gibt es bei ihnen
dass sie durch gekämpft haben wir haben
leider in einigen europäischen ländern
eine unterschiedliche entwicklung und
entscheidungsstruktur gehabt die
österreichischen experten haben sich
dafür ausgesprochen weiter zu impfen
daher gab es hier auch keinen impfstoff
in österreich und wir sind natürlich
froh über die entscheidung der ema die
dieses vorgehen jetzt auch noch einmal
bestätigt hat also der impfstoff der
ohnehin schon zugelassen da wurde jetzt
noch einmal von der ema auch empfohlen
das kam für uns wenig überraschend und
insofern werden wir auch alle impfstoff
für die zugelassen sind weiter verwenden
es gibt ja ohnehin keine impfpflicht das
heißt jeder kann frei entscheiden ob er
sich impfen lassen möchte oder nicht
was bedeutet das jetzt für das image von
astrazeneca da gab es in deutschland den
stopp in anderen ländern auch in anderen
nicht
und schon vorher gab es ja probleme dass
einige diesen impfstoff eben nicht
wollen haben sie sorge dass das astra
zenica jetzt ein großes imageproblem hat
was sollte man da tun
natürlich gibt es eine gewisse
verunsicherung in der bevölkerung aber
ich glaube durch die klare entscheidung
zumindest bei uns unseres nationalen ins
gremium durch die klare entscheidung
auch der jetzt bin ich eigentlich ganz
optimistisch dass die bevölkerung auch
wieder vertrauen in den impfstoff
gewinnen kann und ich glaube das
wichtigste ist immer sozusagen einen
möglichst breiten auch globalen blick zu
haben und es sind in europa inklusive
großbritannien fast 20 millionen
menschen mit astrazeneca geimpft worden
weltweit wieder in vielen ländern
eingesetzt also ich glaube wir können
darauf vertrauen dass in europa nur
impfstoffe zugelassen werden die auch
sicher sind die wirkliche gefahr ist das
virus und nicht die impfung braucht
vorbilder braucht dass politiker wie sie
braucht es deutsche politiker prominente
die sagen und jetzt vorangehen und sich
mit astra zenica impfen lassen also bei
uns gibt es nach wie vor mehr als genug
menschen die sich impfen lassen wollen
und es ist eigentlich eher der impfstoff
knapp und nicht die zahl der menschen
die sich
aber wer das will ich doch jetzt zu
sagen wir wir ziehen welche vor zum
beispiel sie selbst überlassen ob sie in
österreich schon angekündigt dass ich
mich mit astrazeneca ihn zulassen werde
einfach um der bevölkerung auch zu
zeigen dass ich vertrauen in diesen
impfstoff hab aber aber nicht sofort
richtig sondern erst dann wenn sie dran
sind würde mich gerne sofort impfen
lassen
aber wir haben in österreich das klares
system für das ich auch stehe dass
ältere und variable gruppen zuerst dann
kommen und nicht ein 34-jähriger und
insofern sind zunächst einmal die
älteren menschen dran und das ist doch
aber sie könnten ja damit eben gutes
vorbild sein und dafür sorgen dass dann
ältere sich überhaupt impfen lassen das
ist die diskussion die es immer wieder
gibt dass es jetzt eigentlich vorbilder
bräuchte nicht erst ein paar monaten
wenn sie dann dran werden oder wer weiß
vielleicht auch länger sondern jetzt
sofort also wenn es zu wenig menschen
gebe die sich impfen lassen wollen wäre
ich der erste der hier dankbar wäre und
auch bereit wäre mit gutem vorbild voran
zu gehen aber noch einmal wir hatten
genug ihm vordrängler in österreich wir
haben eigentlich die situation dass sehr
viele menschen auf ihren impftermin
warten und auf grund der impfstoff
knappheit leider länger warten müssen
als uns das lieb ist und insofern stellt
sich diese frage im moment nicht aber
ich habe bereits angekündigt sobald
nicht rankommen lasse ich mich mit
astrazeneca impfen so wie viele andere
menschen auch jetzt gab es in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten immer
wieder diskussionen um die frage wie
viel impfstoff ist wirklich da wurde das
verteilt sie haben kritisiert dass zum
beispiel dänemark mehr impfstoff
bekommen hat als österreich und andere
wie gehen sie damit um jetzt und was
sollte die europäische union tun
also ich habe kein problem damit dass
dänemark mehr impfstoff falls
deutschland oder österreich hat um das
geht es nicht sondern es gibt einige
europäische länder die sehr sehr wenig
impfstoff haben bulgarien lettland aber
auch kroatien oder tschechien und das
ist höchst problematisch weil die
europäische union hat immer gesagt sie
kümmert sich um die impfstoff
beschaffung und es gibt gleich viel
impfstoff für alle mitgliedsstaaten zur
gleichen zeit das haben die staats und
regierungschefs immer so beschlossen die
gesundheits beamten haben jetzt andere
systeme in einem steering board
vereinbart
das nicht zur gleichen zeit alle gleich
viel impfstoff ausgeliefert bekommen
oder vertreter mit dabei war und genau
den wir jetzt auch gott sei dank nicht
mehr in diesem gremium haben der
gesundheitsminister hat diesen vertreter
auch von seiner aufgabe enthoben was
glaube ich dringend notwendig war und
daher mache ich auch niemandem einen
vorwurf dass das system jetzt zu ist wie
es ist ich glaube nur wir sollten es
dringend verändern weil es hat europa
nichts davon wenn einige länder wie
bulgarien lettland und andere
zurückfallen und dort einfach deutlich
weniger zur impfstoff zur verfügung ist
und darum bin ich der
kommissionspräsident im sehr dankbar die
hier auch einen korrekturmechanismus
vorgeschlagen hat wir haben intensiv
gearbeitet mit kaiser bei antec mit der
kommission mit vielen mitgliedstaaten
dass wir zusätzlich von kaiser bei antec
impfdosen bekommen für die länder die
eben bisher zu wenig erhalten haben
dadurch muss kein land eine dose abgeben
aber es wird denen geholfen die zu wenig
haben jetzt haben sie die beiden bayern
tech gründer hier in berlin geehrt zum
axel springer preis zum zum award für
die leistung die sie erbracht haben für
die schnelle entwicklung des impfstoffs
des bauerntags impfstoff ist es nicht
tatsächlich so dass die meisten menschen
momentan am liebsten bayern tag hätten
und bräuchten wir davon in europa
vielleicht einfach viel mehr je mehr im
stift desto besser und insbesondere wenn
es von bayer pfizer ist natürlich wir
werden in österreich genauso wie in
deutschland die möglichkeit haben alle
menschen bis zum sommer zu impfen das
heißt vor dem sommer wird jeder der
geimpft werden möchte zumindest eine
erste impfung angeboten aber was kommt
denn anders als israel als duo
großbritannien ist wir sehen jetzt dass
die klubs wieder öffnen lage sagen wenn
israel
da wird doch der europäischen union
jeden tag vor augen geführt wie langsam
wie schlecht das eigentlich gelaufen ist
oder ja natürlich ist das frustrierend
dass hier andere länder deutlich
schneller waren als die europäische
union
aber ich glaube trotzdem ist es wichtig
jetzt auch positiv in die zukunft zu
blicken
es ist noch eine gewisse durststrecke
die
hier haben aber ich glaube wichtig ist
dass wir im sommer spätestens zur
normalität zurückkehren können
je schneller das impfen funktioniert
desto besser wir sind für jede dose
dankbar die wir bekommen in der sekunde
wo wir sie bekommen wird auch alles
sofort verimpft wir impfen derzeit in
österreich 30.000 menschen jeden tag wir
könnten
logistisch weit über hunderttausend
menschen jeden tag impfen
der impfstoff ist in dem ausmaß noch
nicht da aber ursula von der leyen
schall michelle viele andere auf
europäischer ebene kämpfen tagtäglich
dafür dass die lieferungen mehr werden
und das ist auch gut so obwohl es nicht
mehr impfstoff gibt in österreich und
sie deswegen nicht schneller impfen
können wie sie sagen gibt es in
österreich kein lockdown mehr wie in
deutschland in deutschland sind die
geschäfte immer noch geschlossen zum
beispiel
es gab kleinere öffnungs schritte aber
keine großen und man schaut weiter sehr
auf die inzidenz zahl die es in
deutschland aber viel viel geringer als
in österreich ist diese incidents zahl
in wahrheit gar nicht mehr so wichtig
was öffnung an der glaube dass die
ansteckungszahlen und somit die inzidenz
extrem relevant ist aber natürlich sind
auch andere faktoren relevant zum
beispiel die frage wie viel wird
getestet welche menschen stecken sich an
sind die jünger oder älter und ist das
wachstum bei den ansteckungszahlen ein
exponentielles oder ist das nur ein
moderat lineares wachstum und wir haben
in österreich vor sechs wochen die
entscheidung getroffen dass wir öffnen
wollen wir haben die schulen und auch
den handel geöffnet und ich glaube das
ist eine gute entscheidung war ja die
ansteckungszahlen steigen das war
erwartbar aber derzeit gelingt es noch
durch intensives testen dass dieser
anstieg der ansteckungszahlen ein
linearer und noch nicht exakt glaubt
darin wenn sie denn ausschließen naja
einloggen kann man nie ausschließen denn
keiner ist ein prophet und kann
vorhersagen wie sich die
ansteckungszahlen entwickeln aber ich
kann sagen dass wir mit der derzeitigen
entwicklung der letzten wochen zufrieden
sind es ist gut dass wir geöffnet haben
seit fünf wochen gehen die menschen in
österreich wieder in die geschäfte
wir haben dadurch
viele wieder an ihren arbeitsplatz
zurück bringen können wir haben die
kinder wieder in der schule und wir
verbinden das mit einer intensiven
testung das heißt jeden jede woche
werden in österreich rund zweieinhalb
millionen menschen getestet das ist mehr
als ein viertel unserer bevölkerung und
die tests sind kein allheilmittel aber
sie helfen ist dass das wachstum der
ansteckungszahlen zumindest gebremst wie
zum testen haben wir bei bild getitelt
da sind wir die böse ist mussten sie
darüber schmunzeln warum läuft aus
deutschland so schlecht ich glaube es
ist nicht sinnvoll sich da ständig zu
vergleichen und zu schauen was läuft wo
aber sind anlagen müssten sich schon ich
glaube dass deutschland sehr gut
unterwegs ist mit sehr niedrigen
ansteckungszahlen ich glaube dass wir
natürlich durch die öffnung schritte
jetzt etwas höhere ansteckungszahlen
haben als deutschland wir wissen dass
das testen kein allheilmittel ist aber
in unserem fall sind wir überzeugt davon
dass die intensiven tests einfach einen
beitrag dazu leisten dass öffnung
schritte möglich sind und wir haben uns
eben dafür entschieden dass wir die
schule öffnen aber die kinder müssen
getestet werden wer in die volksschule
geld wird dort dreimal die woche im
moment in österreich getestet
das schützt nicht zu 100 prozent vor
infektionen
aber es bremst das infektionsgeschehen
wenn sie jetzt auf ostern schauen dass
die große debatte auch in deutschland
was ist dann möglich zu ostern
und da sagen einige naja preisen sollen
auch in deutschland unterbunden werden
man soll nicht nach rügen fahren dürfen
oder an die nordsee ostsee allerdings
was möglich ist wir könnten nach
mallorca wir könnten in die türkei
verreisen ist das nicht vollkommen ab so
etwas hier passiert das so zu sagen
innerhalb länder oder auch nachbarländer
wie zum beispiel nach österreich ist
schwierig ist zu reisen aber weltweite
reisen eigentlich überall hin sind kein
problem und manchmal kann man sogar
einfach ohne corona das wiederkommen
er hat kann ich jetzt die deutschen
regelungen nicht kommentieren bei uns
ist es so dass wenn man ins ausland
reist das ist natürlich eine intensive
testpflicht und teilweise auch garantien
verpflichtungen gibt und daher sind
jetzt die urlaubsreisen ins ausland
nicht sonderlich populär im moment wir
glauben dass wir möglichst schnell
natürlich auch das reisen wieder möglich
machen und die grenzen dicht noch sind
nicht wir hoffen dass es möglich ist die
grenzkontrollen möglichst schnell wieder
abzubauen wir wollen den tourismus in
österreich natürlich auch so schnell wie
möglich wieder hochfahren und wir freuen
uns wenn wir dann auch wieder viele
gäste in österreich begrüßen können aus
deutschland und dass der urlaub sicher
ist der gehört auch dazu dass das
infektionsgeschehen unter kontrolle ist
und mit der impfung nähern wir uns dem
von tag zu tag mehr und das ist gut so
herzlichen dank sebastian kurz
österreichs bundeskanzler hier spricht
bild live vielen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren